David says there are only two ways to see it. Either he succeeded in inviting the devil into a church camp in Wisconsin or he didn't. It was right around this time of year. David was 12. Back home in Sheboygan, he went to a religious school. It was pretty strict, fundamentalist. And one summer night around the campfire he and his friends started talking about all these supernatural things they had heard of.
大卫说看待这件事只有两种方式。要么他成功地在威斯康星州的一个教会营地里招来了恶魔，要么他没有。那是每年的这个时候。大卫当时12岁。在他家乡希博伊根，他上的是一所宗教学校。学校非常严格，属于基要派。一个夏天的夜晚，在营火旁，他和朋友们开始谈论起他们听说过的所有超自然事物。
Not just ghost stories, but have you ever used a Ouija board? Do you believe in that stuff? And then stories of like, my friend-- Whatever it was, like oh, they were using a juice glass for the Ouija board, and it filled with smoke while they were doing it, you know? Just sort of scaring ourselves and--
不仅仅是鬼故事，还有你有没有玩过通灵板？你相信那些东西吗？然后就是像我朋友那样的故事——不管是什么，比如哦，他们用果汁杯做通灵板，结果在操作的时候杯子里充满了烟，你知道吗？就只是在吓唬自己，然后——
Right, which is one of the best parts of camp.
对，这也是夏令营最棒的部分之一。
Right. And then the next thing I remember is we all went to sleep. And I woke up in the middle of the night. I don't know if I was half in a dream, or what. But I heard what I thought was something flying over the cabin, this sort of like, whoosh. And in my mind-- with all of the conversation that had gone on earlier in the evening-- I thought it was the devil, that all this talk had somehow opened up some door, like if you use a Ouija board you can bring spirits.
没错。接下来我记得的就是我们大家都睡着了。我在半夜醒来。我不知道我是半梦半醒，还是怎么回事。但我听到我以为是有什么东西飞过小屋，那种呼啸声。在我的脑海里——伴随着当天晚上早些时候所有的谈话——我以为那是恶魔，认为所有的这些谈论在某种程度上打开了某种门，就像如果你使用通灵板，你就能招来灵魂一样。
And I knew my friend had a crucifix that he had brought with him, this sort of three inch metal crucifix. And I woke him up. And I said, can I have that crucifix?
我知道我朋友带了一个十字架，那种三英寸长的金属十字架。我把他叫醒了。我说，能把那个十字架借给我吗？
Somehow-- and I know you'll be shocked to hear this-- they all survived that night safely. And the next morning when they all went to the showers, David told the other guys about the sound that he had heard in the middle of the night. And they all laughed at him. And later that morning, coming back from sailing, he was going to the cabin to change out of his swimsuit right before lunch. And he sees this storm rolling in.
不知怎么地——我知道你听到这个会很震惊——他们那天晚上都平安无事地活了下来。第二天早上他们去淋浴时，大卫告诉其他男孩他在半夜听到的声音。他们都嘲笑他。那天晚些时候，午餐前他从航海回来，正要回小屋换下泳衣。他看见一场风暴正席卷而来。
And my mind was still full of these ideas of Ouija boards, and the supernatural, and the devil, and all that stuff. And first of all, I started imagining this storm as coming from the devil, this sort of rumbling off in the distance as coming from the devil. And for whatever reason, my reaction was to sort of challenge the devil, to sort of be like, OK, come on, bring it on. Come and fight me, or fight us, let's see what you got. I'm at a church camp. And I'm with God. And you're not. And all that.
我的脑子里仍然充满了通灵板、超自然、恶魔以及所有这些东西的想法。首先，我开始想象这场风暴是恶魔带来的，远处传来的隆隆声也是恶魔带来的。不管什么原因，我的反应是去挑战恶魔，就像是，好吧，来吧，尽管放马过来。来跟我打，或者跟我们打，看看你有什么本事。我是在教会营地。我和上帝在一起。而你没有。诸如此类。
But I also remember saying, six, six, six, over and over again, which is just more like a curiosity thing to see what would happen, just this sort of childhood curiosity.
但我还记得我一遍又一遍地说着“666”，这更像是一种好奇，想看看会发生什么，只是那种孩童般的好奇心。
Right, and taunt him a little.
对，还稍微挑衅了他一下。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, taunting him.
对，对，对，在挑衅他。
Well that seems to do the job, because right away it starts to pour. And not just pour this light summer drizzle. This was a torrential, Old Testament downpour, the kind where your clothes are immediately sopping wet, you're drenched instantaneously. David thought, OK, that worked. And he got back to his cabin, and changed his clothes for lunch. And he saw the guy who he had borrowed the crucifix from the night before, whose name was Joe.
嗯，这招似乎奏效了，因为紧接着就下起了倾盆大雨。不是那种轻微的夏季细雨。这是一场猛烈的、旧约式的暴雨，衣服瞬间就会湿透，你瞬间就被淋成了落汤鸡。大卫想，好吧，这管用。他回到小屋，换了衣服去吃午餐。他看到了前一天晚上借给他十字架的那个家伙，他的名字叫乔。
And I said to Joe, do you want me to wait for you to go to lunch? Because we would often walk to lunch together. We were buddies. And he said, no, just go ahead without me.
我对乔说，你要我等你一起去吃午餐吗？因为我们经常一起去吃午餐。我们是哥们儿。他说，不用了，你先走吧。
And then I put my parka on. And I'm rushing to the mess hall. And just as I'm about to get to the mess hall, there is the loudest thunder that I'd ever heard in my entire life, just this humongous crack of thunder. And I didn't see anything. I don't remember seeing a flash or anything like that. But the next thing I know, one of our counselors comes running from behind, just white as a ghost. And he just says, they've been hit. They got hit. And about 50 yards behind me, lightning had struck. And six kids got struck in all.
然后我穿上派克大衣。我匆忙赶往食堂。就在我快到食堂的时候，我听到了这辈子听过最大的雷声，就是那种巨大的雷鸣声。我什么也没看见。我不记得看到闪电或者类似的东西。但接下来我知道的是，我们的一位辅导员从后面跑过来，脸色惨白得像个鬼。他只是说，他们被击中了。他们被击中了。就在我身后大约50码的地方，闪电击中了。总共有六个孩子被击中。
The six kids included Joe, who had told David not to wait up for him. As the ambulances arrived, David and all the other campers were ushered into the mess hall. And it took a few days before they were told exactly what happened. The chaplain made an announcement at services in front of everybody.
这六个孩子中包括乔，他曾告诉大卫不要等他。救护车到达时，大卫和其他所有营员被带进食堂。过了几天，他们才被告知到底发生了什么。牧师在仪式上当着所有人的面宣布了这件事。
And he gets up there, and sort of takes a deep breath. His hands are folded in front of him. And I think he names off all the names. He says, these six kids were struck by lightning. There was this boy named Rico who was killed instantly. And then he said, Joe survived-- and I just remember this pause. And I was thinking that he was going to say, but he's in a coma. And then he said, Joe survived-- until Friday. And I mean I just collapsed. I just collapsed on the ground. I think it would be impossible not to feel that-- especially at the age of 12-- not to feel that I had done something to make that happen.
他站在那里，深吸了一口气。他的双手叠在胸前。我想他念出了所有人的名字。他说，这六个孩子被闪电击中了。有个叫里科的男孩当场死亡。然后他说，乔幸存了下来——我记得当时有片刻停顿。我以为他要说，但他陷入了昏迷。然后他说，乔幸存了下来——直到周五。我的意思是，我整个人崩溃了。我直接瘫倒在地上。我想如果不觉得那是——特别是在12岁的时候——不觉得是我做了什么导致了这件事，那是不可能的。
David still had the metal crucifix that Joe had given him the night before he had been hit by lightning. David knew what he had secretly asked the devil to do. And so while everybody at camp took the news really hard, he might have taken it the hardest.
大卫仍然保留着乔在被闪电击中前一天晚上给他的那个金属十字架。大卫知道他秘密要求恶魔做了什么。所以当营地里的每个人都觉得这个消息很难接受时，他可能觉得最难受。
I had been told that you don't mess with spirits. You don't mess with that kind of stuff, because it's real. Spirits are real. And ghosts are real. And the devil is real. And I had very directly challenged the devil. And it resulted in somebody I was close to being killed.
我被告知不能招惹灵体。你不能招惹那种东西，因为那是真实的。灵魂是真实的。鬼魂是真实的。恶魔是真实的。而我直接挑战了恶魔。结果导致我亲近的人被杀。
So David went to his counselor. And the counselor had him talk to the priest. And all the adults said kind of what you would expect. It wasn't David's fault. He shouldn't blame himself. Don't worry about it. But because this was a church camp, David had expected something very different. It was confusing, this reaction he was getting from the adults.
所以大卫去找了他的辅导员。辅导员让他去和牧师谈谈。所有的成年人都说了你意料之中的话。这不是大卫的错。他不应该责怪自己。别担心。但因为这是一个教会营地，大卫期待着完全不同的东西。成年人的这种反应让他感到困惑。
When the adults told you, don't worry about it. It wasn't the devil. Did you feel like no, no, no. That's not what you taught me.
当大人们告诉你，别担心。那不是恶魔干的。你有没有觉得，不，不，不。那不是你们教我的。
Yeah, it's kind of like after I talked with the priest, I thought, don't you believe this, dude? I mean it's like here you are, a priest. And I'm telling you this very serious thing happened within the system that you advocate. And then you're just telling me to ignore it. It's almost like oh we'll drop this because it's convenient now. It's like it's more convenient to not believe this. So we'll just not do it right now. Let's just suspend it for this one circumstance.
是的，这就好比我和牧师谈过之后，我想，老兄，你不相信这个吗？我的意思是，你是一个牧师。我告诉你，在你所倡导的体系内发生了这种非常严重的事情。而你却只是告诉我忽略它。就好像哦，我们要放弃这个话题，因为它现在很方便。就好像不相信它更方便。所以我们现在先不谈这个。让我们在这个特定情况下把它搁置起来。
This one circumstance, the biggest thing that could possibly happen.
这一个特定情况，可能发生的最重大的事情。
Right. This stuff is only real as long as it's not taken really seriously.
对。这些东西只有在不被认真对待时才是真实的。
For a couple of years right after the lightning strike, David used to tell people what happened so he could see their reactions. He wasn't sure what to think-- if it was the devil at work or not-- and he wanted to gauge what other people thought. But after a while he stopped telling people. It's such an intense story that even with people who didn't believe in the devil, it seemed to contaminate how they saw him. It seemed to raise a question about him.
在雷击后的几年里，大卫经常告诉别人发生了什么，以便观察他们的反应。他不确定该怎么想——这是否真的是恶魔在作祟——他想衡量一下别人的想法。但过了一段时间，他不再告诉别人了。这是一个如此强烈的故事，以至于即使对于那些不相信恶魔的人来说，这似乎也玷污了他们看待他的方式。这似乎引发了关于他的质疑。
And slowly, over the next few years, David stopped believing what he'd been taught. He stopped believing the devil exists, and is out there throwing lightning bolts at whoever he wants.
慢慢地，在接下来的几年里，大卫不再相信他所受的教导。他不再相信恶魔存在，也不再相信恶魔就在外面随意向任何人投掷闪电。
I sort of wonder how much of me not believing that has to do with the fact that when I was a kid something happened that, if I continued to believe that the devil can work that way, would make me sort of a killer. There is no in between. It made it untenable to continue believing the devil is real.
我有点纳闷，我不相信这一点在多大程度上与这个事实有关：小时候发生的一件事，如果我继续相信恶魔能以那种方式行事，会让我成为一个杀人犯。中间没有地带。这使得继续相信恶魔是真实存在的变得站不住脚。
Are you afraid that some people are going to hear you describe this on the radio, and they'll think, well actually you've got it wrong, and in the way they see the world, you actually did call on the devil, and that's what killed your friend?
你是否担心有些人会在广播里听到你的讲述，他们会想，其实你错了，在他们看待世界的方式中，你确实召唤了恶魔，而这就是杀害你朋友的原因？
I'm not afraid that that will happen. I know that that will happen. I know that people will hear this and think that I brought the devil down on my friend.
我不担心那会发生。我知道那一定会发生。我知道人们听到这个故事会认为是我把恶魔带到了我朋友身上。
And what do you want to say to them?
那你有什么想对他们说的吗？
I don't know. I don't know if I have anything to say to them. What can you say to somebody who blames you for a death that you don't think is your fault?
我不知道。我不知道我是否有什么要对他们说的。你能对那些因为一场你认为不是你错的死亡而责怪你的人说什么呢？
Well today on our show, Life After Death, we have people on the show today in a situation that most of us never imagine we're going to be in. And in fact, the people on the program never thought that they would be in the situation they are in. You can't make a bigger mistake. You can't fix it once somebody is dead. These people are haunted by the role they played in somebody's death.
今天我们的节目《余生》，我们节目中的人们正处于一种我们大多数人从未想象过自己会身处的境地。事实上，节目中的这些人从未想过他们会陷入这样的境地。你犯不下更大的错误了。一旦有人死亡，你就无法挽回。这些人被他们在别人死亡中所扮演的角色所困扰。
And even in situations where everyone says they're blameless, where they seem blameless, they have a hard time feeling blameless. Stay with us.
即使在每个人都说他们没有过错，他们看起来确实没有过错的情况下，他们也很难觉得自己没有过错。请继续收听。
Act One, Guilty As Not Charged. Darin Strauss tells this story. It's a true story, though we've changed everybody's name but Darin's, out of consideration for the family of the girl in this story, who Darin calls Celine Zilke. Here's Darin Strauss.
第一幕，《有罪却未被指控》。达林·施特劳斯讲述了这个故事。这是一个真实的故事，尽管为了考虑故事中女孩家人的感受，我们更改了除达林以外所有人的名字，达林称她为塞琳·齐尔克。下面是达林·施特劳斯。
Half my life ago I killed a girl. It happened in 1988. I had just turned 18. And my friends and I were headed to shoot a few rounds of putt-putt golf. We had a week of high school left before graduation. I was driving. Far ahead, on the right shoulder, a pair of tiny bicyclists bent over their handlebars. It was a four lane highway. And my Oldsmobile was in the left lane, going south. I think I futzed with the radio. A song I liked had come on.
半生前，我杀了一个女孩。那是1988年。我刚满18岁。我和朋友们正要去打几轮迷你高尔夫球。毕业前还有最后一周的高中生活。我在开车。前方很远处的右侧路肩上，有一对小小的骑自行车的人弯着腰。这是一条四车道的高速公路。我的奥兹莫比尔车在左侧车道，向南行驶。我想我当时在摆弄收音机。我喜欢的一首歌响了起来。
Then one of the riders did something. I remember just that, a glitch up ahead. After a wobble or two, the bicyclist hopped into the road, maybe 30 feet ahead of me. My tires lapped up the distance that separated us. Then suddenly the bicyclist made a crisp turn into the left lane, just 10 feet ahead of my hurrying car.
然后其中一个骑车人做了个动作。我只记得那个，前方出现了一个故障。摇晃了两下后，骑车人跳到了路上，距离我大概30英尺远。我的轮胎迅速拉近了我们之间的距离。突然，骑车人急转进入左侧车道，距离我正在疾驰的车仅有10英尺远。
For a second, her dark blond hair appeared very clearly in my windshield. I remember a kind of mechanical curiosity about why this was happening and what it might mean. The next moment has been, for all my life, a kind of shadowy giant. I'm able-- tick by tick-- to lay out each second. Radio, friends, thoughts of bailing on mini-golf and heading to the beach, distance between car and bicycles closing. Anything could still happen.
有一秒钟，她那深金色的头发非常清晰地出现在我的挡风玻璃上。我记得一种机械式的好奇，为什么会发生这种情况，这可能意味着什么。接下来的瞬间，我余生里一直像是一个阴影般的巨人。我能够——一点一点地——铺陈开每一秒。收音机、朋友、放弃迷你高尔夫直接去海滩的想法、汽车和自行车之间的距离在缩小。任何事情都可能发生。
And then it's too late. My forearm hooks to protect my eyes. My friends shout. And I picture a cartoon of my foot disappearing under the dash, kicking down for the break, reaching farther than any leg can go. Yet the hood of my car met Celine Zilke at 40 miles an hour. Her head cracked the windshield. I remember the yellow reflector from her spokes flipping past us and over the roof.
然后一切都太迟了。我的前臂钩住以保护眼睛。我的朋友们大喊大叫。我脑海里出现了一幅卡通画，我的脚消失在仪表盘下，猛踩刹车，伸得比任何腿能伸到的地方还要远。然而，我的引擎盖以每小时40英里的速度撞上了塞琳·齐尔克。她的头撞碎了挡风玻璃。我记得她辐条上的黄色反光片从我们身边飞过，翻过了车顶。
The car made it onto the grassy median. I must have done all the normal driverish things, put on the hazards, killed the engine. I must have stepped onto the grass. I just have no memory of how I got there.
车开到了草地隔离带上。我一定做了所有司机该做的正常事情，打双闪，熄火。我一定下车走到了草地上。我只是完全不记得我是怎么过去的了。
Celine Zilke, the girl I killed, was 16. And I knew her. She went to my school. She was an 11th grader. I can see her playing field hockey in blue gym shorts, settled in beside friends on the concrete benches of the court yard, scribbling notes in the public speaking class we took together. Celine had sat by the window.
塞琳·齐尔克，那个被我杀死的女孩，16岁。我认识她。她和我同一个学校。她是11年级的。我能看到她穿着蓝色运动短裤打曲棍球，和朋友们坐在庭院的混凝土长椅上，在我们一起选修的演讲课上胡乱记笔记。塞琳曾坐在窗边。
Now I walked to where Celine lay in the road. I didn't know who I'd hit, or even that we'd had a serious collision. I thought in terms of broken arms and getting in trouble with my parents. Then I reached her and noticed the peculiar stillness of her face, which transformed her. I didn't recognize her. Celine's eyes were open. But her gaze seemed to extend only an inch or so. A small imprinted purple horseshoe of blood was pressed in the space between her eyebrows.
现在我走到塞琳躺在路上的地方。我不知道我撞到了谁，甚至不知道我们发生了一起严重的车祸。我以为只是手臂骨折，或者会被父母责骂。然后我靠近她，注意到她脸上那种奇特的平静，这让她整个人都变了。我认不出她了。塞琳的眼睛睁着。但她的目光似乎只能延伸一英寸左右。在她眉心之间压着一个很小的紫色马蹄形血印。
I think maybe she's hurt, my friend Dave said. This might seem an obvious or even a dense statement when you hear it now, but not if you were there. I could feel my breathing rev up, and that's all.
我想也许她受伤了，我的朋友戴夫说。如果你现在听到这话，这看起来可能是一个显而易见的甚至是迟钝的陈述，但如果你当时在那里就不会这么想了。我能感觉到我的呼吸变得急促，仅此而已。
A tragedy's first act is crowded with supporting players, policeman scribbling in pads and making radio calls, witnesses crimping their faces, EMS guys folding equipment. I must have managed to ask about Celine's condition, because at some point the cops told me that she was unconscious but still alive. I remember talk of cardiac arrest, of a medevac helicopter on its way.
一场悲剧的第一幕挤满了配角，警察在笔记本上潦草地写着并打着呼叫电话，目击者皱着眉头，急救人员收着设备。我一定设法询问了塞琳的情况，因为在某个时候，警察告诉我她昏迷了，但还活着。我记得有人谈到心脏骤停，还有一架医疗直升机正在赶来。
I had the strangest feeling that everyone was responding appropriately to what must have been an emergency. But I still didn't have the feeling there was anything to freak out about. This was something that was being fixed.
我有一种最奇怪的感觉，每个人都在对必须是紧急情况的事情做出适当的反应。但我仍然没有觉得有什么好惊慌的。这是一件正在处理中的事情。
Police had suspended traffic on both sides of the highway. My friends made cameo appearances as standers, mullers, back rubbers. I thought, how strange that in normal life we touched each other so rarely.
警察已经暂停了高速公路两侧的交通。我的朋友们作为站立者、思考者、拍背者客串登场。我想，在正常生活中我们很少有肢体接触，这真是太奇怪了。
The most embarrassing memory of that day was when two teenage girls materialized from one of the stopped cars nearby. They were pretty and not from my school. I remember they were both in shorts and white sleeveless undershirts. One of them smelled strongly of suntan oil.
那天最尴尬的记忆是，两名十几岁的女孩从附近的一辆停下的车里冒了出来。她们很漂亮，不是我学校的。我记得她们都穿着短裤和白色无袖背心。其中一个身上散发出浓烈的防晒油味。
Hey, she said, were you in that crash? Her voice was a mix of shyness, concern, and pure nosiness. Yeah, I said, I was. Having acknowledged my own sensuality and drama, and knowing the girls were still watching, I dropped to my knees and covered my head with my hands, fingers between the ears and temples, like a man winning the US Open.
嘿，她说，你是那起车祸的当事人吗？她的声音混合了羞涩、关心和纯粹的好奇。是的，我说，是我。意识到自己的感性和戏剧性，并且知道女孩们还在看着，我跪了下来，双手抱头，手指插在耳朵和太阳穴之间，就像一个赢得美国公开赛的男人。
This movieishly emotional reaction acted out for girls I'd never see again is one more stomach-turning fact of that afternoon. Aw, the first girl said, coming over to me. I know it wasn't your fault.
这种在以后再也见不到的女孩面前表现出的电影般的情感反应，是那个下午让我感到反胃的又一个事实。噢，第一个女孩说，朝我走过来。我知道这不是你的错。
My father arrived. Someone must have called him. This was before cellphones. It was the sight of my dad that day, the sadness on his face, that made it finally real somehow. And when he hugged me I totally lost it, collapsed all at once into tears, as I never had before and haven't since.
我父亲赶到了。一定有人给他打了电话。那是在手机普及之前。那天看到我爸爸，看到他脸上的悲伤，才终于让一切变得真实起来。当他拥抱我时，我彻底崩溃了，泪水夺眶而出，前所未有，之后也再未有过。
I got a call the next day, saying that Celine died in the hospital before her parents-- who had been on vacation-- got the chance to see her.
第二天我接到一个电话，说塞琳在医院去世了，她的父母——当时正在度假——没能有机会见到她。
The police, Celine's biking companion that day, and several cars of eye witnesses all said there was nothing I could have done. No charges were filed.
警察、那天和塞琳一起骑车的人，以及几辆车的目击者都说我什么也做不了。没有提出任何指控。
A police detective, Paul Vitucci, later told the newspaper, quote, "for an unknown reason, her bicycle swerved into the traffic portion of the street. And she was immediately struck by the car. There was no way he"-- meaning me "--could have avoided the accident, no way whatsoever."
警察侦探保罗·维图奇后来告诉报社，引述：“由于未知原因，她的自行车转向了街道的交通部分。她随即被车撞倒。他”——指我——“根本无法避开这场事故，根本没有任何办法。”
I thought, how could that be possible? I saw it all happen. It was hard to believe there was only one way this could have gone. It was hard to believe she had to die. Maybe I'd been distracted. Maybe I could have swerved away somehow. Maybe I hadn't felt the right amount of alarm just before the girl jumped into my lane.
我想，这怎么可能？我都看到了整个经过。很难相信这件事只有一种发展结果。很难相信她必须死。也许我分心了。也许我本可以设法避开。也许在女孩跳入我的车道前，我没有感觉到足够的警觉。
After the story appeared in the local paper, everyone knew. I remember coming down to breakfast and my parents showing me the article. And I remember thinking, that was it. There was no hiding from this. My parents, after offering quiet voiced assurances, encouraged me not to beat myself up about it. You should go to a movie, they said. And so a friend and I drove to Stand and Deliver.
报道在当地报纸刊登后，大家都知道了。我记得下楼吃早餐，父母把文章给我看。我记得当时想，就是这样了。无处可藏了。父母在给予轻声安慰后，鼓励我不要为此折磨自己。你们应该去看场电影，他们说。于是我和一个朋友开车去看了《为人师表》。
At the multiplex, the weirdness of my having gone out, of not being under house arrest, slowly sunk in. We traveled to another town. I didn't want to be seen trying to enjoy myself. I didn't want people to know that I was capable of having any emotion, but constant remorse. We left before the end of the movie.
在影院里，我竟然出来看电影、没有被软禁的怪异感慢慢袭来。我们去了另一个城镇。我不想被看到试图让自己开心。我不想让人们知道我除了不断的悔恨之外，还能有任何其他情绪。电影还没结束我们就离开了。
I spent the next few days behind a closed door, talking to no one in particular, a parrot in underpants and socks who kept asking, will I get over this? That Monday or Tuesday, I heard there was a school-wide memorial assembly. Celine's teachers, friends, and coaches giving tribute to her, the quote, "girl who's been so cruelly taken from us." I hadn't had the guts to be there that day, or back to school at all.
接下来的几天我都在关着的门后度过，不跟任何人说话，像一只穿着内裤和袜子的鹦鹉，一直问，我会好起来吗？那个周一或周二，我听说学校要开一场全校纪念会。塞琳的老师、朋友和教练都在向她致敬，引用“那个被如此残忍地从我们身边夺走的女孩”。那天我没有胆量去参加，甚至根本没敢回学校。
My friend Eric told me that near the end of that assembly, a teacher I barely knew and didn't very much like stood from the crowd and walked straight to the microphone. This was a surprise. He hadn't been designated to speak. Along with the sadness, he said-- taking the mic from the principal-- I know there's a lot of anger here. This teacher wasn't a hippie. He was given to wearing pullover Baja shirts to social studies class. I had laughed behind his back many times.
我的朋友埃里克告诉我，在纪念会快结束时，一位我几乎不认识也不怎么喜欢的老师从人群中站起来，径直走向麦克风。这很让人惊讶。他并没有被指定发言。除了悲伤，他说——从校长手中接过麦克风——我知道这里有很多愤怒。这位老师不是嬉皮士。他经常穿着套头巴哈衬衫来社会研究课。我在他背后嘲笑过他很多次。
Great emotion is justified in tragic events like these, he said. But we should take a second to remember that Darin is a student in the North Shore community too. The reports tell us he wasn't at fault. And I'm sure we can agree, he's a good person.
在这些悲剧事件中，强烈的情绪是合理的，他说。但我们应该花点时间记住，达林也是北岸社区的一名学生。报告告诉我们他没有过错。而且我相信我们可以同意，他是一个好人。
It was years before I wrote to thank him, this guy I didn't really know, who was decent enough to perform this simple act of kindness for a student he barely knew.
过了好几年，我才写信去感谢他，这个我并不真正认识的家伙，他足够体面，为一名他几乎不认识的学生做了这个简单的善举。
I returned to class about a week after the accident and a few days before the funeral. I hadn't heard what kids were saying about me. But I was met at the school's front door with a dirty look from one Steffi [? Gayheart ?], a friend of Celine's. What high schooler wouldn't glare hard at the driver who had killed her friend?
事故发生约一周后、葬礼前几天，我回到了课堂。我没听清孩子们在议论我什么。但我在学校前门遇到了斯蒂芬妮 [？盖哈特？] 投来的厌恶目光，她是塞琳的朋友。哪个高中生不会狠狠地瞪那个撞死她朋友的司机呢？
I expected my day would be filled with these black looks. But in the classrooms and corridors there quickly grew around me a zone of silence and inviability, except when my friends would suddenly mount brief, haphazard campaigns of everything's normal, quoting lines from Fletch and slapping my book bag, and calling me a dick.
我以为我的一天会充满这种仇视的目光。但在教室和走廊里，我的周围很快形成了一个沉默且不可见的区域，除了我的朋友们会突然发起短暂、杂乱的“一切正常”的运动，引用《福莱奇》里的台词，拍打我的书包，叫我混蛋。
My friend Frank assured me that they also-- without my knowing it-- had started in on the high school equivalent of caucusing, push polling, of lobbying for votes. Come on, they'd say to anyone still on the fence, the undecideds. Wasn't it kind of suspicious how she just turned into his car? Did you ever think of that? True friends, they'd say quietly, we have to be there for Darin too. We have to support him too.
我的朋友弗兰克向我保证，他们也——在我不知道的情况下——开始了高中版的游说和拉票。加油，他们会对那些还在观望的人说，那些未定派。她竟然直接撞进他的车里，这不是很可疑吗？你有没有想过这一点？真正的朋友，他们会轻声说，我们也必须支持达林。我们也必须支持他。
Steffi [? Gayheart, ?] at the end of that first day, approached my locker. I'm sorry I, she barely managed to say, I support you. She told it straight to my Keds. At the time, I was sure it was insincere. She'd been peer pressured into saying that. She definitely wasn't sorry. But now, I don't know. Maybe she meant it. It couldn't have been easy for her to talk with me, the kid who killed her friend.
斯蒂芬妮 [？盖哈特？] 在第一天结束时走到我的储物柜前。对不起，我，她好不容易才说出来，我支持你。她是对着我的Keds运动鞋说的。当时，我肯定那是不真诚的。她是迫于同伴压力才那样说的。她绝对不感到抱歉。但现在，我不知道。也许她是真心的。对她来说，跟我这个撞死她朋友的孩子说话肯定不容易。
A few days after I'd gone back to school, Celine had her funeral. It was just my dad accompanying me. At the church entrance, I remember taking a breath, grabbing the door handle, then plunging into the crowd. This was and remains the hardest thing I've ever had to do. I couldn't help but be scared.
我回学校几天后，举行了塞琳的葬礼。只有我爸爸陪我。在教堂入口处，我记得深吸了一口气，抓住门把手，然后冲进人群。这是我做过的最困难的事情，现在依然如此。我不由自主地感到害怕。
But I was also kind of relieved to feel tears on my face, tears some part of me knew would look good. And they were real, these tears.
但我同时也感到一丝释然，感觉到脸上有泪水，泪水中的一部分我知道看起来会很好。而且它们是真实的，这些泪水。
I was afraid someone might stand up and yell at me, here in front of everyone. One old man looked at me like he wanted to kill me with his bare hands. And then I had to face Celine's parents.
我担心有人会站出来在众人面前对我大吼。一位老人看着我，眼神仿佛想徒手杀了我。然后我不得不面对塞琳的父母。
Some morticianal functionary shunted me into a back chamber where they were. Her father, a big man, moved toward me with a surprisingly light step. He didn't know what to do with his face. It was soft and jowly. And he wore glasses that gave him a Tom Bosley, Happy Days vibe. In the long moment before he found words, and as he took my hand, he settled on an expression of, I will be friendlier than you have any right to expect me to be.
某个殡葬职员把我带到了他们所在的后室。她的父亲，一个大块头男人，以出奇轻快的脚步向我走来。他不知道该怎么处理自己的表情。那是柔软而松垂的。他戴着一副眼镜，给人一种汤姆·博斯利在《快乐时光》里的感觉。在找到话语之前的漫长时刻，当他握住我的手时，他定格在一个表情上，即：我会比你有理由期待我表现出的更友好。
"You're Darin," he said. My voice and face behaved-- or prevailed upon to behave-- as if this were a regular meeting between cordial strangers. Celine's mother joined us. She attempted a smile, but without much success. Her body clenched as she steeled herself for an odious act. Then she hugged me quickly. And just as quickly, she pulled away.
“你是达林，”他说。我的声音和表情表现得——或者被强迫表现得——就像这是礼貌的陌生人之间的一次普通会面。塞琳的母亲加入了我们。她试图微笑，但不太成功。她的身体绷紧了，她在为一种令人厌恶的行为做心理准备。然后她迅速拥抱了我一下。同样迅速地，她又拉开了距离。
"I know it was not your fault. They all tell me it was not your fault." She was speaking as kindly as she could. And so her voice was dim. "But I want you to remember something. Whatever you do in your life, you have to do it twice as well." She looked at me with exhausted eyes, "because you are living it for two people now. Can you promise me?"
“我知道这不是你的错。他们都告诉我这不是你的错。”她尽可能温柔地说话。所以她的声音很低沉。“但我希望你记住一件事。无论你一生中做什么，你都必须做得比别人好两倍。”她用疲惫的眼睛看着我，“因为你现在是为两个人活着的。你能答应我吗？”
It didn't feel right. I was going to commit to something I had no control over, or even really understood. I nodded. I'd accepted her request without saying a word, as you would a benediction.
这感觉不对。我要承诺一件我无法控制、甚至不太明白的事情。我点了点头。我接受了她的请求，没有说一个字，就像接受祝福那样。
Then I was standing before Celine's open coffin. I don't remember how I got there, who had taken me. I only remember the whispers at my back, the weight of 400 eyes on me. Celine's eyes were now closed. And she looked almost like herself again.
然后我站在塞琳敞开的棺材前。我不记得我是怎么过去的，是谁带我过去的。我只记得背后的窃窃私语，400双眼睛盯着我的压力。塞琳的眼睛现在闭上了。她看起来几乎又像她自己了。
Next I was hurrying from the coffin, past all the people who stared. As I approached the exit, my dad kept buzzing in my ear, keep your head up, just keep your head up.
接着我匆忙离开棺材，经过所有盯着我的人。当我走向出口时，我爸爸一直在我耳边嗡嗡作响，抬头挺胸，就这样抬头挺胸。
I hadn't realized I'd been slouching my head. I felt buoyed by a great respect for my father at that moment. And I wondered if I would ever know the things grownups know. And I lifted my head.
我没意识到我一直低着头。那一刻，我对父亲产生了一种巨大的敬意。我想知道我是否永远能知道大人们知道的事情。我抬起了头。
About two weeks later, I graduated and left town. I didn't stay for summer break. College offered a sort of witness protection program. Everyone in my high school knew. No one at Tufts did. And while I was there, they never would.
大约两周后，我毕业了，离开了那个城镇。我没留下来过暑假。大学提供了一种类似证人保护计划的东西。高中里每个人都知道。塔夫茨大学没有人知道。当我在那儿的时候，他们永远也不会知道。
But I did make one important stop in town before I'd left, to Celine Zilke's parents' house. They had invited me to come by whenever at the funeral. So I thought they expected this visit. I went alone. I even imagined a cozy welcome. They would smile, maybe touch my cheek, we'd cry together.
但在我离开之前，我确实在城里做了一个重要的停留，去了塞琳·齐尔克的父母家。他们在葬礼上邀请我随时过来。所以我以为他们期待这次访问。我独自前往。我甚至想象了一个温馨的欢迎。他们会微笑，可能会摸摸我的脸颊，我们一起哭。
I knocked. My stomach shuttered up into my throat. No one seemed to be home. Leaning an ear to the door, I made out the clumps and risings of voices. After an extra swallow for courage, I knocked again. One man's voice became louder and more distinct, getting closer. The door opened. It was Celine Zilke's father. After seeing me, Mr. Zilke turned back toward the room.
我敲了敲门。我的胃紧缩到喉咙里。家里似乎没人。把耳朵靠在门上，我听到了人声的嘈杂和起伏。为了壮胆又咽了口唾沫后，我再次敲门。一个男人的声音变得更响亮、更清晰，越来越近。门开了。是塞琳·齐尔克的父亲。看到我后，齐尔克先生转回房间。
"Look who it is." He still wasn't facing me. "It's Darin." He said this as if he was proud of me for having showed, as if he had that very instant been defending me to someone.
“看是谁来了。”他还是没有正视我。“是达林。”他说这话时，好像为我能出现而感到自豪，好像他那一刻一直在向某人维护我一样。
"He's here to say how sorry he is," he told the room, "to apologize." There were a few other people there in the Zilke's den, fellow grievers whom I didn't know, who didn't say a word.
“他是来道歉的，”他告诉屋里的人，“来赔礼道歉。”齐尔克家的小书房里还有几个人，我不认识的哀悼者，他们一言不发。
And I wondered, was I there to apologize? The Zilkes said they knew it wasn't my fault, hadn't they? Mr. Zilke gestured me to the couch and offered me an iced tea.
我心想，我是来道歉的吗？齐尔克夫妇说他们知道这不是我的错，不是吗？齐尔克先生示意我坐在沙发上，递给我一杯冰茶。
"How are you?" I said stupidly.
“你们好吗？”我愚蠢地说。
"OK," he said. "Yes. OK, you know."
“还好，”他说。“是的。还好，你知道的。”
"Good," I said, "good," taking a long sip before I put the glass down. Then that was finished.
“那就好，”我说，“那就好，”我喝了一大口才把杯子放下。然后事情就结束了。
The room got quiet. I couldn't believe how quiet, how quickly. So I shouldn't have come. The visit was a check cashed too soon. They didn't want me there. I didn't want to be there.
房间安静了下来。我简直不敢相信竟然这么安静，这么快。我真不该来。这次访问是一张被提前兑现的支票。他们不希望我来。我也不想来。
Before long, Mr. Zilke shepherded me to the door with another, "no matter what, we would never blame you, Darin."
没过多久，齐尔克先生把我带到门口，又说了句：“无论如何，我们永远不会责怪你，达林。”
I left there covered in a feeling of globby naivete. There was little chance, I thought, that I'd ever see them again.
离开时，我感到一种粘稠的幼稚。我想，我再见到他们的机会很小。
A month into my freshman year of college I got an official letter saying that Celine's parents were suing me for $1.5 million. It took five years of depositions and meetings before the case finally went away.
大一开学一个月后，我收到一封正式信件，说塞琳的父母起诉我赔偿150万美元。经过五年的取证和会议，这个案件最终不了了之。
Right before the trial, the Zilke family lawyer advised them to take a small amount of money-- go away money, my insurance company's lawyer called it-- that payment corporations give to a family when they know their client isn't at fault. There was-- they were told-- no case.
审判前，齐尔克一家的律师建议他们接受一小笔钱——我保险公司的律师称之为“走人费”——即当公司知道客户没有过错时付给家庭的那笔钱。当时被告知——他们根本没有胜算。
At college, I dove into physics and psychology textbooks, where I discovered a weird solace in computation. If you're doing 45, and the girl with the bicycle cuts 10 feet in front of you, impact will take place in something like 700 milliseconds. Human perception time-- not only to see a hazard, but to designate one as such-- is generally accepted to consume some 220 milliseconds.
在大学里，我沉浸在物理和心理学教科书里，发现在计算中有一种奇怪的慰藉。如果你以45英里的速度行驶，而骑自行车的女孩在离你10英尺远的地方切入，冲击将在700毫秒内发生。人类的感知时间——不仅是看到危险，而且将其定性为危险——通常被认为消耗了大约220毫秒。
Next, the purely neural job of stamping your foot on the brake adds roughly another 500 milliseconds. I was exculpated by 20 milliseconds.
接下来，踩刹车的纯神经工作又增加了大约500毫秒。我被20毫秒证明了清白。
I'd be studying in the library, and tell myself I was going to take a bathroom break or something. And then I'd find myself in the stacks, making sure that my reassuring numbers were still there, still reassuring.
我会在图书馆学习，告诉自己要上厕所什么的。然后我发现自己躲在书堆里，确认我那让人安心的数字还在，依然让人安心。
In the first semester of my freshman year, I took a class called On Death and Dying, which was a lot of Elisabeth Kubler-Ross and When Bad Things Happen to Good People. I thought it would make me feel better.
大一上学期，我选修了一门课叫《关于死亡与临终》，里面有很多伊丽莎白·库伯勒-罗斯的观点和《当坏事降临在好人身上时》的内容。我以为这会让我感觉好一点。
After I wrote a paper about my accident, the grad students who taught this touchy feely seminar suggested that I do research into Celine's side of things. I thought this was a terrible idea. But I was an obedient student. So I made blundering, unwanted intrusions into the lives of Celine's friends, the other bicyclist that day, a girl she played field hockey with, a lab partner, anyone whose number I could get.
在我写了一篇关于我的事故的论文后，那些负责这门情感导向研讨班的研究生建议我去做研究塞琳那一方面的情况。我觉得这是个糟糕的主意。但我是一个听话的学生。所以我笨手笨脚地、不受欢迎地闯入了塞琳朋友们的生活，那天和她一起骑车的女孩，她曲棍球队的队员，一个实验室搭档，任何我能弄到号码的人。
I learned that Celine had remade herself, becoming a born again in the months before her death, even though her family hadn't been particularly religious. And then I discovered something that changed how I felt about her death for years when I talked to her friend from the field hockey team.
我了解到塞琳在去世前几个月让自己改头换面，成为了一名重生基督徒，尽管她的家庭并没有那么强烈的宗教信仰。然后，当我与曲棍球队的朋友谈话时，我发现了一件事，这多年来改变了我对她死亡的感受。
"I'm sorry to call like this," I'd said, floundering. "I just am taking this class. I need to find out more about, you know, her, because of the class."
“很抱歉这么打电话，”我说，语无伦次。“我只是在修这门课。我需要找出更多关于，你知道的，她的信息，因为这门课。”
"Wasn't that diary thing weird?" the girl said.
“那个日记的事不奇怪吗？”那个女孩说。
I felt my heart thump. "What diary thing?"
我感觉到心脏怦怦直跳。“什么日记的事？”
"Oh," the girl said. She obviously felt that she'd overstepped. "I assumed you knew."
“哦，”女孩说。她显然觉得自己说漏嘴了。“我以为你知道。”
It turned out that Celine had written in her journal right before the crash, "today I realized I am going to die." Celine's mother had told this field hockey friend about it.
事实证明，塞琳在事故发生前在日记里写道，“今天我意识到我要死了。”塞琳的母亲曾告诉这位曲棍球队的朋友这件事。
"Thank you," I'd said as I hung up. I may have even said it again after I put down the phone. "Thank you."
“谢谢你，”挂断电话时我说。放下电话后我可能又说了一遍。“谢谢你。”
Celine, I decided, had taken her own life. That's why she turned right in front of my car. That was how I got through my twenties and even my early thirties, believing with full certainty that she'd committed suicide, that I was no more responsible for the accident than the bullet that comes out of the gun's chamber.
我断定，塞琳是选择了自杀。这就是为什么她直接转到我的车前。这就是我度过二十多岁甚至三十出头的方式，完全确定她是自杀的，我在事故中的责任并不比子弹从枪膛射出大。
I wouldn't let myself think what now seems obvious, that when she wrote, "today I realized that I'm going to die," she may have just meant, today I realized I will die someday.
我不让自己想那些现在看来显而易见的事情，当她写下“今天我意识到我要死了”时，她可能只是指，“今天我意识到我终有一天会死。”
Before the accident, I wasn't so introspective. I'd had nothing to be introspective about. And I never had anything that I hid from the world. But now I did. For years, I told pretty much no one, which seemed the only way to treat a thing I was so uncomfortable with.
事故发生前，我没那么内省。我没什么可内省的。我从来没有任何向世界隐瞒的东西。但现在有了。多年来，我几乎没告诉任何人，这似乎是处理一件我如此不自在的事情的唯一方式。
I didn't tell any friends. I thought it would taint how they saw me. I thought they wouldn't want to know. Who would want to know? Even I didn't want to.
我没告诉任何朋友。我想这会玷污他们看我的方式。我想他们不会想知道的。谁会想知道呢？连我自己都不想。
When I went on dates, I'd be talking-- just getting to know you stuff-- and I'd wonder, when do I tell her? The few times I did tell women, it was only after I had known them a while. Even then, I hated the reaction it got. It made them feel tender. They hugged me. I felt gross for having told them, like I was using the accident to score points.
当我开始约会时，我会交谈——仅仅是了解对方的内容——我会想，我该什么时候告诉她？那几次我确实告诉了女性，那也是在认识她们一段时间之后。即便如此，我还是很讨厌由此产生的反应。这让她们感到温柔。她们拥抱了我。我觉得因为告诉她们而感到恶心，就像我在用事故来博取好感一样。
Though one time-- in my earlyish twenties-- I ended up on a first date at the movie I Know What You Did Last Summer. There is a pivotal scene, where a teenager hits somebody with his car. I just couldn't watch anymore. I told my date, "we have to get out of here." This was like 20 minutes in.
虽然有一次——在我二十出头时——我第一次约会看了一部电影《我知道你去年夏天干了什么》。有一个关键场景，一个青少年开车撞到了某人。我实在看不下去了。我对约会对象说：“我们必须离开这里。”这大概是电影开始20分钟后。
She didn't want to leave. And when we got outside, I told her everything. Her response surprised me. She got angry at me. "It's really selfish of you to feel bad for yourself," she said. "Don't you ever think of her?"
她不想走。当我们走到外面时，我告诉了她一切。她的反应让我吃惊。她对我生气了。“为自己感到难过真是自私，”她说。“你就没想过她吗？”
I didn't know what to say. Of course I thought of Celine.
我不知道说什么好。我当然想塞琳。
"Yes," she said. "But do you think about her enough? How can you go on living with that?"
“是的，”她说。“但你有足够多地想她吗？你怎么能带着那种心情继续生活？”
I excused myself. And I left for the subway without walking her home. A little later, she called me to apologize. She said she'd often thought of committing suicide in high school by swerving into oncoming cars. All right, I'd said.
我告了罪。我离开了，去坐地铁，没有送她回家。过了一会儿，她给我打电话道歉。她说她在高中时经常想通过转向迎面驶来的车来自杀。好吧，我说。
Celine's father making up goofy songs just for her when she was a baby. Celine crying after she tripped stealing third base in little league. Celine on crunching roller skates, hurrying away from the neighbor's dog. I try to imagine her before the accident. And sometimes I try to imagine the life she would have gone on to live had it never happened. Maybe this was my way of pretending she hadn't died that day.
塞琳的父亲在她还是个婴儿时为她编造傻乎乎的歌。塞琳在小联盟偷三垒被绊倒后哭泣。塞琳穿着旱冰鞋咔哒咔哒地逃离邻居家的狗。我试着想象事故前的她。有时我试着想象如果事故没发生她会继续过的生活。也许这是我假装她那天没死的方式。
As I got into my twenties and thirties, Celine stayed with me. I thought of her, of course, any time I drove by a bicyclist, which happens a lot more often than you'd think. I know that's not something most people even register.
随着我进入二十多岁和三十多岁，塞琳一直在我身边。当然，我开车经过骑自行车的人时，总会想起她，这种情况比你想的要多得多。我知道这甚至不是大多数人会注意到的事情。
As I got older, she'd show up with me on job interviews. Would the prospective employer find out what I'd done? Was this an ambitious enough job for two lives? Because I'd absorbed Celine's mother's request, I had to live well enough and successfully enough for two. I thought of her at my wedding, and when my wife got pregnant.
随着年龄增长，她会和我一起去面试。未来的雇主会发现我做过的事吗？这份工作对两条生命来说足够有抱负吗？因为我吸收了塞琳母亲的请求，我必须为两个人活得足够好、足够成功。我在婚礼上想到了她，在我妻子怀孕时也想到了她。
Now I'm twice as old as I was when the accident happened. And I don't know when I changed. There was no single moment. But somehow I've grown into a different way of seeing it all. Because I was alive in a certain place, Celine Zilke isn't anymore.
现在我的年纪是事故发生时的两倍了。我不知道我是什么时候改变的。没有单一的时刻。但不知何故，我已经长成了一种看待这一切的不同方式。因为我活在特定的地方，塞琳·齐尔克就不再存在了。
That's all this was, a highway mathematical error. In the US there are over 40,000 traffic deaths a year. But it was me, and it was Celine. She was someone that I happened to, someone who happened to me.
仅此而已，这只是高速公路上的一场数学错误。在美国，每年有超过4万起交通死亡事故。但那是我，那是塞琳。她是我碰巧遇上的人，也是碰巧遇上我的人。
The police told me if I'd swerved the car differently, I might have flipped it. If that had happened-- if I had died and Celine had lived-- I think I'd like her not to remember, not to have at 18, at 23, even at 35 years old to contend with a stranger there at all her intimate moments.
警察告诉我，如果我把车转向不同，我可能会翻车。如果那发生了——如果我死了而塞琳活了下来——我想我希望她不要记得，不要在18岁、23岁、甚至35岁时还要面对一个陌生人出现在她所有的私密时刻。
And I'd like her to be spared the feeling she'd traveled for two decades with a ghost. I'd be OK if she forgot me, though I can't forget her.
而且我希望她能免于那种仿佛带着幽灵旅行了二十年的感觉。如果她忘了我，我会没事的，尽管我无法忘记她。
Darin Strauss. He is the author most recently of the novel More Than It Hurts You.
达林·施特劳斯。他是小说《比伤害你更深》的作者。
A reporter for Washingtonian Magazine a few years ago interviewed lots of drivers who had been in accidents and killed people. It wasn't their fault. And this article quotes a psychologist named Ed Hickling, who wrote a book about overcoming the trauma of a car accident. And he says that drivers who have done nothing wrong in an accident are actually at greater risk of developing post-traumatic stress disorder about the accident than people who were really at fault for an accident. Quote, "someone who falls asleep at the wheel knows what they can do to prevent future accidents. Innocent drivers," Hickling says, "realize they're at the mercy of the universe."
几年前，《华盛顿人》杂志的一名记者采访了许多在车祸中杀人的人。那不是他们的错。文章引用了一位名叫埃德·希克林的心理学家的观点，他写了一本关于克服车祸创伤的书。他说，在车祸中没有做错任何事的司机，比那些真正有错的司机，患上车祸创伤后应激障碍的风险更高。引用：“一个在方向盘后睡着的人知道他能做些什么来防止未来的事故。无辜的司机，”希克林说，“意识到他们受制于宇宙的摆布。”
[MUSIC - "GHOST" BY TERESE TAYLOR]
[音乐 - 特蕾丝·泰勒的《幽灵》]
Coming up, one positive side to being incarcerated, it is a lot easier to sleep at night. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
即将播出，入狱的一个正面因素是，晚上更容易睡觉。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Life After Death. We have stories of people who are unable to stop thinking about things that they have done that may have resulted in somebody else's death. We have arrived at Act Two of our show, Soldier of Misfortune.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种各样的关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，《余生》。我们有关于人们无法停止思考他们可能导致他人死亡的事情的故事。我们的节目进入了第二幕，《不幸的士兵》。
You may have heard stories about veterans coming home from Iraq and Afghanistan, and then committing acts of violence here at home, sometimes against wives and other family members. There was a big New York Times series about this, which found 121 cases of vets who killed someone once they came home from those wars.
你可能听说过退伍军人从伊拉克和阿富汗回家，然后在国内犯下暴力行为的故事，有时是针对妻子和其他家庭成员。《纽约时报》对此做了一个大型系列报道，发现有121起退伍军人回家后杀死某人的案件。
But we don't often hear about this from the vet's perspective. Chris Neary talked with an Iraq war vet who has attacked people close to him. This is somebody who did three tours of duty in the Mideast in the build up and early part of the Iraq War. Here's Chris Neary.
但我们不常从退伍军人的角度听到这些。克里斯·尼里与一位曾攻击身边人的伊拉克战争老兵交谈。这是一个在伊拉克战争筹备期和初期在中东执行了三次任务的人。下面是克里斯·尼里。
I met John in the fall of 2007. I had been hanging around the VA Hospital in Chicago, working on a story about veterans with PTSD, post-traumatic stress disorder. John stood out. He was really well-liked at the hospital, comfortable with the other vets and the staff.
2007年秋天，我遇见了约翰。我一直在芝加哥的退伍军人医院附近徘徊，做一篇关于患有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的退伍军人的报道。约翰脱颖而出。他在医院里很受欢迎，和退伍军人以及工作人员相处得很好。
He was interested in me too. He wanted to get a job in radio some day. And so, after talking to him at the hospital, we agreed to meet at his apartment for another interview. I wasn't really sure what I was after. He seemed like the kind of guy who could help me understand something about how war affects you.
他也对我很感兴趣。他希望有一天能在广播电台工作。所以，在医院和他交谈后，我们约定在他公寓进行另一次采访。我真的不确定我想要什么。他看起来像那种能帮我理解战争如何影响一个人的人。
I met him at his apartment the day after Thanksgiving. There was an unopened package of dinner rolls and a brand new baking pan and baster that clearly hadn't been used. His apartment smelled stale. There were VA papers everywhere.
感恩节后的第二天，我在他的公寓见了面。有一包未开封的晚餐卷和全新的烤盘和涂油刷，显然从未使用过。他的公寓闻起来陈旧。到处都是退伍军人事务部的文书。
He said he'd been waiting all day for me. But when I got there, he suddenly got embarrassed, and started hurriedly cleaning up his apartment. I was surprised how different he seemed from the guy I'd met at the VA. John said I shouldn't be.
他说他等了我一整天。但我到那儿时，他突然感到尴尬，匆忙开始收拾公寓。我惊讶于他与我在退伍军人医院见到的那个人看起来如此不同。约翰说我不应该感到惊讶。
We have two faces. There's two faces to everybody that has been in a war. You have a face that wants to get help, an optimistic face. And then you have like the real face. And at the hospital they're like, everybody's doing well. And everybody's cool.
我们有两张面孔。每个参加过战争的人都有两张面孔。你有一张想要寻求帮助的乐观面孔。然后你有像真实面孔的那种。在医院里，他们会说，大家的情况都很好。每个人都很酷。
And I'm like you really don't know that Roger can't get on the elevator with anybody. I used to not even go into stores to get food. I would pay drug addicts to go in there and get me food, because I didn't even want to go in the store. That's the stuff that really happens, what people are really acting like. I haven't left the house since like Tuesday.
而我会说，你们真的不知道罗杰不能和任何人一起坐电梯。我以前甚至不进商店买食物。我会花钱雇瘾君子去那里帮我买吃的，因为我甚至不想进商店。那就是真正发生的事情，人们的真实表现。我从周二起就没出过门。
John and I talked about a lot of things, his family, high school, the service. Iraq, it turned out, was just one of the many traumas John had suffered during his life. He had been abused and molested as a kid, kicked around foster families.
约翰和我谈论了很多事情，他的家庭、高中、服役。事实证明，伊拉克只是约翰一生中所遭受的众多创伤之一。他小时候曾受到虐待和猥亵，在寄养家庭中被踢来踢去。
But when he was five he was basically rescued. He got adopted into a big family that was known around the neighborhood as the Huxtables. And he settled into an uneventful and happy childhood and adolescence. He had a girlfriend and a best friend, got good grades. He went to church, and played drums in his high school's marching band. If you knew him then, he says, you would probably have called him a band geek.
但他在五岁时基本上获救了。他被一个大家庭收养，那个家庭在邻里间被称为“赫克斯特布尔一家”。他进入了一个平静且快乐的童年和青春期。他有女朋友和最好的朋友，成绩很好。他去教堂，在高中行进乐队里打鼓。如果你那时认识他，他说，你可能会称他为“乐队书呆子”。
We would all meet up in the band room. And basically we would just talk about the dullness that we all had. Most of the time, just we went over the sheet music. I'm trying to think of something, like maybe somebody stuck something in a tuba, or something. But there is really not much.
我们会聚集在乐队室。基本上我们只是聊聊我们共同的沉闷。大多数时候，只是翻阅乐谱。我在想些什么，比如可能有人把什么东西塞进了大号里，之类的。但真的没太多东西。
John's adopted father, sister, and brother joined the military. And after high school, so did John. This was 1999.
约翰的养父、姐姐和弟弟都参加了军队。高中毕业后，约翰也去了。那是1999年。
He deployed to Kuwait in early 2002. He saw heavy fighting in Iraq. And then when he got out of the military in 2005, he moved to Louisiana. He closed on a house in Gulfport, Mississippi, a month before Hurricane Katrina hit. He lost everything, his car, his home. That was sort of a final blow to his stability.
他在2002年初被部署到科威特。他在伊拉克经历了激烈的战斗。2005年退伍后，他搬到了路易斯安那州。在卡特里娜飓风袭击前一个月，他在密西西比州格尔夫波特买了一栋房子。他失去了一切，他的车，他的家。这对他原本就脆弱的稳定性来说算是最后一击。
He made his way back to Chicago with the last of his money. And now here he was, alone on Thanksgiving weekend, afraid to leave his messy apartment, with me. It's a bleak picture. But compared to some of the other vets at the VA with PTSD, he was doing OK. He'd been getting treatment at the VA for five months. And the people who he'd met there were optimistic about his future.
他用最后的钱回到了芝加哥。现在他独自在感恩节周末，不敢离开他凌乱的公寓，和我在一起。这景象很凄凉。但与退伍军人医院的其他PTSD老兵相比，他做得还可以。他在退伍军人医院接受治疗已有五个月。他那里认识的人对他未来都很乐观。
He had a girlfriend. And they had a young daughter. And he'd even been venturing outside occasionally, like when he took a trip with his girlfriend to downtown Chicago.
他有一个女朋友。他们有一个年幼的女儿。他甚至偶尔会冒险出门，比如和女朋友去芝加哥市中心玩了一趟。
It was like I'd went to Disney World. And all I did was walk down State Street and down Michigan. Got a couple ice cream cones, piece of pizza. And it was like Disney World, because I hadn't been outside in so long.
就像去了迪士尼乐园一样。我所做的只是沿着州街和密歇根大道走。买了几个冰激凌蛋筒，一片披萨。感觉就像迪士尼乐园，因为我已经很久没出门了。
And my girl thinks that I think she's ugly or something, because I don't want to go outside. She thinks-- My girl is beautiful. I mean, for real. She could be like a model or something. And if you don't take a girl out-- a pretty girl like that-- she's like, what's going on?
我女朋友以为我觉得她丑什么的，因为我不想出门。她认为——我女朋友很漂亮。我是说，真的。她看起来能当模特什么的。如果你不带女朋友出去——那么漂亮的女孩——她会想，怎么回事？
After our conversation, we made plans to talk again. There was more I wanted to find out. And John seemed like he enjoyed the company. We went back and forth, and finally set up a plan to meet at the VA. But when I got there, he stood me up.
谈话结束后，我们计划再谈。我还想找出更多东西。约翰看起来很享受这种陪伴。我们来回沟通，终于定下在退伍军人医院见面的计划。但我到了那儿时，他爽约了。
A couple weeks later, I got an email from his therapist at the VA, a guy named Dr. John Mundt. There had been a very ugly development, the email read. But Dr. Mundt couldn't tell me any more, because, he said, it was a criminal matter.
几周后，我收到了他在医院治疗师约翰·蒙德博士的电子邮件。发生了一件非常丑陋的事，邮件写道。但蒙德博士不能告诉我更多，因为他说这是刑事案件。
That was in January of 2008. It took six months for Dr. Mundt to get the OK from John's lawyer to talk with me about what had happened. But finally he told me what little he knew.
那是2008年1月。蒙德博士花了六个月才得到约翰律师的许可，与我讨论所发生的事情。但他最终告诉了我他所知道的细节。
He said that John had been over at his girlfriend's grandmother's house. Things became heated between John and his girlfriend, Dominique.
他说约翰当时在女朋友的祖母家。约翰和他的女朋友多米尼克之间发生了激烈争执。
They had an argument. And at some point, he brought out this knife that he carried. And I think she asked her grandmother to take the kids out of the room. But the grandmother wanted to intervene, and wanted to stop John from hurting her granddaughter.
他们吵了一架。在某个时刻，他拿出了他随身带的那把刀。我想她请求祖母把孩子带出房间。但祖母想介入，想阻止约翰伤害她的孙女。
So at that point, I think John was cutting Dominique. She was hurt. She was cut pretty badly. And John then went into the kitchen, and lay down on the floor and started crying.
所以在那一点上，我想约翰在切伤多米尼克。她受伤了。伤得很重。然后约翰进了厨房，躺在地上开始哭泣。
That I distinctly remember her telling me. I mean he had cut her a number of times, and cut the grandmother.
这一点我清楚记得她告诉过我。我是说他割伤了她好几次，也割伤了祖母。
Dominique didn't want to talk with me for this story. But the police crime report runs almost 20 pages, using interviews with Dominique, Dominique's grandmother, two witnesses, and observations of several different arresting officers to reconstruct the events of the night.
多米尼克不想接受我的采访，但这篇报道的警察犯罪记录有近20页，利用了对多米尼克、多米尼克祖母、两名目击者的采访，以及几名逮捕警官的观察，重建了那一晚的事件。
According to the report, John, Dominique, and their one and a half year old daughter had been eating dinner with Dominique's three year old son from another father and Dominique's grandmother. They had all been getting along. Then around 7:00 PM, John and Dominique started arguing about bus schedules.
根据报告，约翰、多米尼克和他们一岁半的女儿正在和多米尼克与前任男友所生的三岁儿子以及多米尼克的祖母共进晚餐。他们相处得都很好。然后大约晚上7点，约翰和多米尼克开始为公交时刻表争吵。
The argument escalated to the point of violence fairly quickly. John ran into the kitchen and grabbed a steak knife, screaming, "I'm going to kill your ass." Dominique's grandmother calmed him down for a while, but then he erupted again. From the police report, quote, "John grabbed Dominique by the hair. John dragged Dominique down to the kitchen floor. John then began slamming her head into the kitchen floor repeatedly."
争吵很快升级到暴力程度。约翰冲进厨房抓起一把牛排刀，尖叫着：“我要杀了你。”多米尼克的祖母曾让他平静了一会儿，但他又爆发了。据警方的报告，引述：“约翰抓住多米尼克的头发。约翰把多米尼克拖到厨房地板上。约翰然后开始反复地将她的头撞向厨房地板。”
Later, he threw Dominique's three year old son across the apartment onto a couch. He grabbed Dominique around the neck, and tried to choke her. He slashed the knife down on Dominique's hand, and then grabbed her, and held the knife to her neck.
后来，他把多米尼克三岁的儿子扔过公寓摔在沙发上。他抓住多米尼克的脖子，试图掐死她。他用刀猛割多米尼克的手，然后抓住她，把刀架在她的脖子上。
He then let her go, sat down next to the refrigerator, and begin to cut himself on the chest. That's when the police arrived. He told them, see I don't care. It doesn't hurt. Later he told the police he wished they'd shot him.
然后他放开了她，坐在冰箱旁边，开始割伤自己的胸部。警察就在那时赶到了。他对他们说，看我不怕。那不疼。后来他告诉警察，他希望他们当时开枪打死他。
It's hard to reconcile the person depicted in this police report with the person I met at the VA. I couldn't imagine this shy, friendly guy hurting anyone, let alone an elderly woman, a three year old, and his own fiancee. And I was very surprised when I'd heard the news that he'd done it. But no one else was, not Dr Mundt, John's therapist, and not John himself.
很难将这份警局报告中描绘的人与我在医院见到的那个人联系起来。我无法想象这个害羞、友好的家伙会伤害任何人，更不用说一位老太太、一个三岁的孩子和他自己的未婚妻。当我听到他做出这种事的消息时，我非常惊讶。但其他人都不惊讶，蒙德博士、约翰的治疗师，甚至约翰自己都不惊讶。
I know that I was capable of it. In no way was I like, no, not me. Anytime I go outside, especially around people that I like, I try to limit the time. That's most of the time why I'm so paranoid, to keep them safe. And I've got to keep them safe from me.
我知道我是有能力做到的。我根本没有那种，“不，不是我”的想法。任何时候我出门，尤其是和喜欢的人在一起时，我都尽量缩短时间。大多数时候我这么偏执的原因就是为了保护他们。我必须保护他们不受我的伤害。
My producer Alex Blumberg and I visited John in jail outside Chicago. And it turns out he had a less clear idea than Dr. Mundt does about what happened that night. In fact, he says he can't really remember it at all. He's been here for seven months, during which time he hasn't been allowed to talk to Dominique.
我的制片人亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我去芝加哥郊外的监狱探望了约翰。结果发现，他对那一晚发生的事情比蒙德博士了解得更模糊。事实上，他说他几乎完全不记得了。他已经在这待了七个月，期间不被允许和多米尼克说话。
He remembers going to Dominique's grandmother's house. He remembers drinking a glass of brandy. He remembers talking to her about cleaning the bathroom. And then--
他记得去多米尼克的祖母家。他记得喝了一杯白兰地。他记得和她谈论打扫浴室。然后——
I remember waking up in here. Still bleeding. I got stitched up some. And I'm like, who cut me? They're like, well you did.
我记得在里面醒来。还在流血。我被缝了几针。我心想，是谁割伤我的？他们说，是你自己。
When you learned what happened-- when you woke up and people told you what happened-- do you remember what your first thought was or your first emotion? Was it like--
当你了解发生了什么时——当你醒来，人们告诉你发生了什么时——你还记得你第一个想法或第一种情绪是什么吗？就像是——
My first thought was that I killed my daughter. I thought I killed my daughter. That was my first thought.
我第一个想法是我杀了我的女儿。我以为我杀了我的女儿。那是我的第一个想法。
When I go to sleep at night, I see little pieces coming back. I can see myself cutting myself. I haven't been able to see cutting Dominique. I try to concentrate on it. I don't know if it's because I don't want to remember.
晚上睡觉时，我看到小片段回放。我能看到自己在自残。我还没能看到割伤多米尼克。我试图集中精力回忆。我不知道是因为我不想记得。
I used to think people would be like, oh man, I can't remember this stuff. What happened? And I'd be like, bull [BLEEP], you remember what happened. And now I know how that feels. But it's scary. To be unsure about what happened. I could have done anything.
我以前以为人们会说，天哪，我不记得这些东西了。发生了什么？我会说，胡说八道，你记得发生了什么。现在我知道那种感觉了。但这很可怕。对发生的事情不确定。我什么都做得出来。
It doesn't surprise me at all to hear that he doesn't remember, because I really believe he dissociated.
听说他不记得了，我一点也不惊讶，因为我真的相信他解离了。
John's therapist, Dr. Mundt, says he has seen this happen many times. He's even seen it happen to John. John was sleeping at the VA when another vet startled him. He flew into a rage, threatened the other vet, but suddenly stopped. Mundt says it was like he shook himself awake. He seemed confused and took off running.
约翰的治疗师蒙德博士说他见过这种情况多次发生。他甚至见过发生在约翰身上。约翰在医院睡觉时，另一名退伍军人吓了他一跳。他勃然大怒，威胁那个人，但突然停了下来。蒙德说这就像他把自己摇醒了一样。他看起来很困惑，跑开了。
Mundt says John and his other patients have experienced intense feelings of war, and that all they need is a taste of those feelings in civilian life to make them believe they are in a life and death situation. This break in perception is what Mundt and other therapists call a disassociative state.
蒙德说约翰和其他病人经历了强烈的战争情感，他们所需要的只是在平民生活中体验到那种感觉，就足以让他们相信自己处于生死关头。这种感知的断裂就是蒙德和其他治疗师所说的解离状态。
And unfortunately, situations where really, really strong feelings are involved. Even if all that was happening was that Dominique was maybe yelling at him or that an argument was escalating, where, in other words, she wasn't necessarily threatening him or a risk to him, he could feel it that way. If those emotions take over, it really can kick somebody into this other gear, where they dissociate. And then people can do all kinds of things that they're not going to really recall afterwards.
不幸的是，在涉及非常非常强烈情感的情况下。即使发生的仅仅是多米尼克可能对他大喊大叫或争吵升级，换句话说，她不一定在威胁他或构成风险，他也可能感觉到是那样。如果这些情绪占据主导，真的可以把一个人带入这种换挡状态，也就是解离。然后人们就会做各种各样事后不记得的事情。
I talked with John in the psych ward of the county jail for almost three hours. And it became clear to me how much I'd missed the first time I had talked with him, the full extent of what he described as the two faces.
我在县监狱的精神病房和约翰谈了近三个小时。我很明显地看出我第一次和他谈时漏掉了多少东西，他所说的“两张面孔”的全部程度。
John had started getting violent almost a year before I met him at the VA. And when I visited him at his apartment in November, his habit of flying unprovoked into a rage was well established.
约翰在我在医院见到他之前近一年就开始变得暴力。当我在11月探访他的公寓时，他无缘无故大发雷霆的习惯已经很根深蒂固。
One of my brothers-- my doctor brother-- we were playing Monopoly. And we were playing craps. It was with Monopoly money. Just something to pass the time until everyone got ready to play Monopoly. And he cheated me. But it's Monopoly money.
我的一个兄弟——那个医生兄弟——我们正在玩《大富翁》。我们在玩掷骰子。用的是《大富翁》里的钱。只是为了打发时间。结果他骗我。但那只是《大富翁》里的钱。
That's what I say now. But once I was like, man, you cheated me, I got angry. And then I really got angry, trying to hurt my brother over some Monopoly money.
我现在这么说。但当时我心想，天哪，你骗我，我生气了。然后我真的发火了，试图为了几张《大富翁》的钱去伤害我的兄弟。
Like what? Like you got into a fight? You were hitting him?
就像什么？你们打架了吗？你在打他？
Right, right, right. And most military people or veterans, we don't fight like regular people fight. We don't throw fists. It's not like a boxing match. It's like, eye gouging, putting you down on the ground, make them not be there anymore. So most of the time when I did get into a physical altercation, people thought that I was trying to kill them. And most of the time that's what it was.
对，对，对。大多数军人或退伍军人，我们不打架像正常人那样打。我们不挥拳头。那不像拳击赛。那是眼睛戳刺，把你按在地上，让你不再在那儿。所以大多数时候，我卷入肢体冲突时，人们认为我试图杀了他们。大多数时候就是这样。
John had put his cousin in the hospital. He'd broken his little sister's arm. Friends, people on the street, car salesmen, he overreacted all the time. He got fired at his last job as a hotel security guard for being too aggressive with the guests. Gradually he alienated his friends and family, to the extent that when I finally met him he was almost completely alone in the city where he'd grown up.
约翰把他的堂弟送进了医院。他弄断了他妹妹的手臂。朋友、路上的人、汽车推销员，他一直反应过度。他在上一份酒店保安的工作中因对客人太激进而被解雇。渐渐地，他疏远了朋友和家人，以至于我最终见到他时，他在他长大的城市里几乎完全孤单。
You could divide the trauma of war into two categories, the bad things that are done to you-- being shot at, gassed, ambushed-- and the bad things you do to other people. A lot of us, I think, assume that for most veterans, what sticks with them is the first category of trauma. They come back edgier, more skittish, and always afraid for their own safety. And that's true for John.
你可以把战争的创伤分为两类，发生在你身上的坏事——被枪击、毒气、伏击——以及你对别人做的坏事。我想，我们很多人假设对大多数退伍军人来说，留在心里的创伤是第一类。他们回来后变得更易怒、更胆小，总是担心自己的安全。这对约翰来说确实是真的。
But the way he's living now is just as driven by that second category of trauma, living with the consequences of what he's done. He feels guilty. And that guilt gets turned into violence. In Iraq, John fired 60 millimeter mortar rounds, which would destroy houses and buildings.
但他现在的生活方式同样受到第二类创伤的驱动，生活在他所作所为的后果中。他感到内疚。内疚转化为暴力。在伊拉克，约翰发射了60毫米迫击炮弹，这会摧毁房屋和建筑物。
It's not like you see some big Arnold Schwarzenegger built guys out there with rippling muscles, and they're coming at you with all these weapons. You see guys with some Michael Jordan gym shoes on, with the same kind of Calvin Klein shirts you got.
你看到的不是那种阿诺·施瓦辛格式的肌肉男，带着鼓胀的肌肉，用各种武器冲向你。你看到的是穿着迈克尔·乔丹球鞋的人，穿着和你一样的卡尔文·克莱因衬衫。
And some of the little kids that are about 10, 11, 12 years old, these kids could be your kids. So I felt sorry. And then you'd see these little kids dead. Why-- people like me-- long distance-- blowing up a house. Then you come and see it's smoldering up. And you've got a pregnant lady there. She is dead, but the baby is still alive. And she's cooking.
有些10、11、12岁的小孩，他们可能是你的孩子。所以我感到难过。然后你看到这些小孩子死掉。为什么——像我这样的人——远距离——炸毁房子。然后你走过去看到它还在冒烟。你看到一个怀孕的女士在那儿。她死了，但婴儿还活着。而她正在像烧焦了一样。
At first I thought that I deserved this-- not being in jail, but being tormented at night when I go to sleep. You got to pay for everything. Everything doesn't go unpunished.
起初我以为我罪有应得——不是坐牢，而是晚上睡觉时受折磨。你必须为你做的一切付出代价。没有什么是没惩罚的。
It would be simpler, he says, if instead of just leaving him to stew over what he did in the war, someone would just cut off his finger, give him a real punishment. Because of his guilt, John doesn't like to talk about what he did in Iraq, not with me, not with his therapist, and definitely not with strangers who find out he was in combat and ask if he killed anyone over there.
他说，如果有人不是让他反思在战争中做了什么，而是直接砍掉他的手指，给他真正的惩罚，那会简单些。因为内疚，约翰不喜欢谈论他在伊拉克做了什么，不跟我谈，不跟他的治疗师谈，更不用说那些发现他参加过战斗、问他是否在那儿杀过人的陌生人。
That's the first thing everybody asks. If you're artillery man, what do you think? But if you know anyone that has actually hurt someone, they're not proud. That's not something that you talk about with someone.
那是每个人问的第一件事。如果你是炮兵，你会怎么想？但如果你认识任何真正伤害过别人的人，他们并不感到自豪。这不是那种你和别人谈论的事情。
I'm not going to go up to a girl that got raped, and be like, you been raped lately? Because it's the same thing. That's how it feels. I've been raped before. That brings on the same kind of feeling.
我不会走到一个被强奸的女孩面前说，你最近被强奸了吗？因为那是同样的事情。这就是感觉。我以前也被强奸过。那会带来同样的感觉。
Was that when you were a kid?
那是你小时候的事吗？
Right, when I was a kid.
对，小时候。
It's weird. I think that most people wouldn't make that connection, being raped and killing somebody or hurting somebody as like the same-- How do you think they are related? What's different and what's similar?
这很奇怪。我想大多数人不会建立起这种联系，被强奸和杀死某人或伤害某人是同样的事情——你认为它们有什么关联？有什么不同和相似之处？
The similarities are I regret both. Both were out of my power. I had no control. It's the same thing, because we don't have any control about what we do. We just do what we're told to do. And you can't forget.
相似之处是我对两者都后悔。两者都超出了我的能力。我无法控制。是一回事，因为我们无法控制我们做的事。我们只是做被告知要做的事。你无法忘记。
I have dreams that repeat over and over. I have a dream where my fiancee is sitting in a chair with her back to me, like one of those little wooden chairs. And she's like in a factory or some room. And there's an Iraqi that cuts her throat. When I go to try to save her, to try to go get him, he disappears.
我不断重复着噩梦。我梦见我的未婚妻坐在椅子上背对着我，就像那种小木椅。她像是在工厂或某个房间里。一个伊拉克人割断了她的喉咙。当我试图去救她，试图去对付他时，他消失了。
And I have another dream where I'm mutilating my little baby, taking her by the legs, and just smashing her against the wall, or tables, or stuff. Yep, every night.
我还有个梦，梦见我肢解我的小宝宝，抓着她的腿，把她撞向墙壁、桌子之类的东西。没错，每晚都是。
Can I ask what you're thinking about now?
能问你现在在想什么吗？
Same dreams. They seem real.
同样的梦。它们看起来很真实。
Dr. Mundt says John is still a good candidate for rehabilitation, even after all this. The fact that he's so verbal is a big thing. He can describe what happened to him in Iraq, and talk about his guilty feelings, which means he's treatable. And he still wants the life he was heading towards back in high school, the life he would have had if he hadn't gone to war.
蒙德博士说约翰仍然是一个很好的康复候选人，即使在发生了这些事之后。他如此健谈是一个大事。他能描述在伊拉克发生的事，谈论他内疚的感受，这意味着他可以治疗。他仍然想要他高中时所期待的生活，那种如果他没去战争本来可以拥有的生活。
John's lawyer is working to reach a pre-trial agreement, where John would be released from jail and put into a program that is sort of like an intense probation, where he would have to stay on his medication and stay away from alcohol. But John is nervous about that. When he was on the outside, he was paranoid. Every stranger he saw on the street, every sound he heard at night was a potential threat, someone coming to get him. He would notice people on the street and start running.
约翰的律师正在努力达成庭前协议，约翰将从监狱释放，进入一种类似严格缓刑的计划，他必须按时吃药且远离酒精。但约翰对此很紧张。他在外面时，他很偏执。街上看到的每个陌生人、晚上听到的每种声音都是潜在的威胁，有人来抓他。他会注意到街上的人就开始跑。
I haven't slept this good since I came home, being in here. I know it sounds strange. But I can sleep. I'm locked in a room by myself, and nobody can get in. I don't feel threatened. I don't have to hear the water dripping in the faucet, or the toilet running, or the birds outside on the trees, and people outside, cars and all that. I just don't hear it. Because it starts to hurt up in your stomach, and in your back, and in your neck, because you're trying to listen all day.
我回家后还没睡得这么好过，在这里。我知道听起来很奇怪。但我能睡觉。我独自被锁在一个房间里，没人能进来。我不觉得受威胁。我不需要听到水龙头滴水，或者马桶冲水声，或者树上的鸟，外面的人、汽车什么的。我就是听不见。因为如果你整天试图去听，你的胃、后背和脖子会开始疼。
I'm getting nervous just thinking about going outside. I'll be getting out of here in a couple weeks. And I can feel it coming back. Just nervous. I feel a little normal while I'm in here.
一想到要出门我就紧张。过几周我就要出去了。我能感觉到那种紧张感又回来了。我在这里面感到稍微正常一点。
John says jail is a good place to practice being normal, to practice having normal conversations, where you don't talk about much. In jail, John says, he'll yell at people, and then actually go back and apologize. He says it's the first time in a long time he's talked to anyone who doesn't have a white jacket or a Ph.D. John says he's not sure what he'll say to Dominique once he's released, or how he'll explain what's happened. He says he wants to apologize, and see if she'll have him back.
约翰说监狱是个练习做正常人的好地方，练习进行普通的对话，不多聊什么。在监狱里，约翰说，他会朝人吼，然后真的回去道歉。他说这是很长一段时间以来他第一次和不是穿着白大褂或拥有博士学位的人交谈。约翰说他不确定获释后会对多米尼克说什么，或者如何解释发生的一切。他说他想道歉，看看她是否愿意收留他。
Chris Neary in Chicago.
克里斯·尼里在芝加哥。
Our program was produced today by Lisa Pollak and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind, [UNINTELLIGIBLE], and P.J. Vogt. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
今天的节目由丽莎·波拉克和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼格、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。阿德里安·马西奥韦茨负责我们的网站。塞思·林德、[听不清]和P.J.沃特提供了制作帮助。杰西卡·霍珀提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can get our free-- absolutely free-- podcasts, and where there is still time to enter our t-shirt design contest. Details and rules-- and there is a cash prize-- at www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里您可以获得我们免费——绝对免费——的播客，现在还有时间参加我们的T恤设计大赛。详情和规则——还有奖金——在www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss Mr. Torey Malatia, who is sure that the devil, himself, is regularly listening to public radio. And of course, though the devil has lots of money, he never pledges.
WBEZ的管理层对我们的节目进行监督，我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生肯定，恶魔本人经常收听公共广播。当然，虽然恶魔有很多钱，但他从来不捐款。
For whatever reason, my reaction was to sort of challenge the devil. Come on, bring it on.
不管出于什么原因，我的反应是去挑战恶魔。来吧，放马过来。
I'm Ira Glass. We'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们下周将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。